all right boogie so with your comedy
slam which is hilarious i had the chance
to watch it whenever i'm telling people
about it
they're almost surprised that you are
like a funny
silly guy so would you describe yourself
as that
i mean i am um i mean it's funny you say
that because you know usually the only
time that i'm seeing this
during my occupation so it's not really
about fun and games at that point
well for me um i take the game seriously
but uh
outside of the lines i'm a goofy
laid-back guy so
i enjoy comedy i enjoy laughing and i
enjoy the vibe
so that's what i'm about now i know
obviously you have
some hilarious guys and you're special
tell me about them and what makes
them you know very special and funny
guys um
well you know guys like mike epps ray
grant and um gary owens they
they've been in the game for a long time
when it comes to the younger guys you
know
the carlos miller and not necessarily
young in age but just young in the game
um you know they bring they bring that
next generation of funny
which i always want that combination i
want some of the older og guys in the
game and
the and up-and-coming so that's kind of
how i go about it
i hear that you are also a bit of a
jokester would you say that's true
yeah i like to joke a lot actually so
okay so i'm putting you on the spot with
this
i'm not asking you to tell me what the
exact joke is
but give me the gist okay i'm gonna name
an nba player and you tell me if you
were making a joke about them what it
would be along the lines of
if okay if we're doing comedy demarcus
we're doing finally
that's crazy are you ready
yeah shoot it's only two or three okay
all right
john wall the usa uh the usa picture
you and i assume you joke about that a
lot with him
yes okay um anthony davis
the unibrow obviously
okay lebron james i mean
the typical hair jokes about broad so
okay last one
uh steph curry that mouthpiece man i
feel bad for it
always hanging out always hanging out
yeah um shifting gears a little bit
um i think you saw that i spoke to mikey
williams a couple weeks ago about
hbcus and the possibility of him going
to an hbcu
and you are a player that he
specifically mentioned as somebody who
reached out to him
and support and encouragement tell me
about that conversation with mikey
um you know i basically sent them a
message saying um
you know you got a chance to you know
change sports
as a whole um start a trend that
should have already you know happened um
you know looking back on it now i wish i
had that opportunity
to you know do it the right way in my
opinion the attention
the the energy that like a kid like
mikey could
take to any hbcu would like i said
change the
you know face of college sports i had a
chance
to be on campus at howard and i guess it
was a time where
you know people may have been switching
whatever the case may be and it was just
like
i was like in awe of like how many black
blacks
i've never seen in my life and
i was just in awe so with that being
said i'm like man like even in that
moment i'm like damn i should have
you know i should have came to howard or
whatever the case may be
obviously anybody who has followed your
career knows that you went to kentucky
so
i guess my question is what has caused
the change meaning what do you
understand now
that maybe you didn't understand then
the business and it's sad to say but
even college it's a business
you know obviously the athletes don't
benefit from it but
everything around it is a business and
it's a reason they want those kids at
the school
that could easily be hbcu with that same
type of attention with that same type of
income
and and it's well deserving it's it's
going to be really interesting to see
and it's
i think that it um gives us a lot of
pride and i think hope to know that the
younger generation is
looking to do that um in the steps that
they're taking right now
so um i totally agree absolutely
absolutely i want you to put on your
analyst hat
give me your predictions who's winning
the championship this year
i don't know i got asked this question
earlier i
honestly don't know if it was the
regular season it was playing out
you know the way it was i think the
lakers
but with the current situation and
everything that's in the play
i mean all it takes is a guy to
test positive and it changes the whole
series
everybody has the same opportunity so
you can't
say it's this is a you know
championship put to the side because
that's not true so um
but it is teams that now have a chance
that didn't have one before
i'll be tuned in to say the least
because i'm excited i feel like it's
going to be a team that nobody expects
what is it going to be like playing
without fans like what do you think the
guys are thinking right now
what can you not say on the court
because
everybody might hear it
the words would be very limited at this
point
okay last one for you just i'm curious
what percentage
of stuff said on the court
can't be heard is it 90 is it 85
like what percentage of stuff is like
this cannot be said
i say about oh that cannot be said it
cannot be said
and and and it's actually being said on
the court yeah like in a normal
70 70 so
okay so we're gonna get 30 of what it's
actually like on the court
no i think you're going to get a whole
70
what i'm saying it's about a good 70
that the people cannot hear
yeah okay so you hitting about 30
on the 90 a good 70 has been you know
blocked out or whatever but with the
court being empty
yeah no well i'm sure hearing everything
will absolutely be comedy so it's going
to be very fitting
for this interview you were a blast like
i said
everybody should watch comedy special it
is available now exclusively on amazon
video on demand
and thank you so much for your time all
right thank you